so in the early debates about the
Constitution
there are folks that wanted a strong
central leadership and other folks who
did because they felt it felt a lot like
George the third how did the existence
of Washington as a person affect the
debate it's amazing so George Washington
that his friends have to plead with him
to come to a constitutional convention
he thinks frankly that rewriting the
rules of the country is it's not going
to work but they finally convinced him
to come and make him president of the
convention and they put him at the front
of the room and he says not almost
nothing during the entire four months
but what he does is at the front of the
room he is a model because remember he
resigned his commission as commander of
the Continental Army and gave up power
he didn't seize the power that he had as
he was basically the biggest celebrity
in America and he gave his Commission
back to the government which was an act
of sublimating his own personal
self-interest for the for the benefit of
the Republic and that's what they that's
the model they wanted for the
Constitution so he didn't say much but
they designed basically as one writer
said that what they were essentially
doing was writing his future Job
Description because everybody in the
room knew he would ultimately become the
president because there was nobody else
in America like him and what was
important was not that he was a general
but it that he had this virtue inside of
him which was that he would know how far
to go and when to stop and when to
protect those liberties and so he sat on
a chair with a son on the back of it and
at the end of the proceedings Benjamin
Franklin who was the only other great
kind of superstar in America who
participated in the convention said that
he looked at that son on the on
Washington's chair and he wasn't sure
whether it was a Rising Sun or a Setting
Sun but now after they finished their
work he had decided that the Sun was
rising which was basically anointing and
blessing everything that had happened
there and this new office of presidency
that they had created that George
Washington was to go walk into and
that's why Washington's statue is in
front of Independence Hall where the
Constitutional Convention took place but
in the in the dialog over four months
you almost never see his words he was
there as a symbol and participant but
not like James Madison
Willson or governor Morris who were in
there in the nitty-gritty of every
little detail do we know what Washington
was thinking did he want the job that he
have a view or he just said hey I'm just
gonna do it what everyone else decides
fortunately they did everything in
secret
Washington was so virtuous that he
didn't even write about it in his diary
now fortunately we have other people who
did keep Diaries and and James Madison
took notes and said have published them
only after all 55 members are dead what
Washington thought is he wanted a
central government because as a general
he knew there had to be an army to
handle rebellions and there had been
Shay's rebellion that had tested some of
the Articles of Confederation so he
wanted a strong government but he was
and he was very worried that having been
successful revolutionaries they could do
what he knew was hard by history which
is that revolutionaries aren't very good
at creating governments and so he knew
that what they were doing was a real
risk and a real gamble he believed that
it could be done however he believed
that a strong national government was
required but then when he was given the
job he was incredibly nervous this
incredible military leader basically
thought that he was he might fail it was
more likely than not that this whole
darn thing would fail and that he might
fail and his as he rode to his
inauguration he kept writing letters and
in his diary talking about how the
expectations of his countrymen were just
too much for him and that was both a
personal worry and he also worried about
monarchy how does monarchy build it so
either when a monarch demands power or
when the mob hands all of the power to
the person and says do everything for us
and gives them ultimate power and what
they knew in the in the convention was
that human beings were sinful and could
not handle power if they were given the
power they would abuse it as surely as
the Sun comes up in the morning and he
was worried that if given too much power
perhaps he could be susceptible to that
and so he was for as confident as much
of a strength of a model of strength as
he was a very nervous guy and it sounds
like an unusual person where the power
at least as the history I've read didn't
corrupt him and he didn't try to do a
power grab that's right Washington was
constantly he was a man
of a rigid code and he believed that the
standards were necessary for the proper
kind of human behavior he wrote a list
of hundred different things that a
gentleman should do to comport himself
in the proper way in society he and and
that's what made him such a good model
I'd like a copy of we'd all be better
but things like clearing your throat how
you behave in the presence of a lady and
and he believed in these codes because
he believed if everybody maintained them
then the system would work you know this
was during the period where Newton's
laws were making people think about a
clockwork universe where if everything
runs if the machine is put together with
tension right so it recognized that
people were not angels tension in the
machine but if everybody did their thing
and the pieces stayed in their lane as
it were then the clock would work and so
he had that code which tried to keep him
in his place and keep everybody else in
his place and he set a standard and then
everybody tried to live up to it as
opposed to saying well that standards a
nice but I'm now gonna go do this and
that's why when he resigned his military
commission and he also undid a coup that
some of his men were planning back when
he was leader of the army they were
basically gonna go to Congress and say
this is in Newburgh New York they were
gonna go to Congress and say unless you
give us our money we're gonna stage a
coup he found out about the plot went to
his men and said this is a sin both
against the Revolution and my own
personal virtue because I put myself on
the line they backed off and and what he
could have done is say let's go let's
ride to Washington and get you your
money you fought in this war your your
wives and children are begging and poor
you deserve this money let's use our
power and authority and take it and he
said no Joseph Ellis the historian
writes about it as being the Last
Temptation of Washington as a general
he's has the chance to grab the power
and he says no we shouldn't do it and
that's why he was a model because he
could resist the pull of power and
that's the the image in which they
wanted to create this new government